if you've had surgery you might remember
starting to count backwards from ten
nine eight and then waking up with the
surgery already over before you even got
to five and it might seem like you were
asleep but you weren't you were under
anesthesia which is much more
complicated you were unconscious but you
also couldn't move form memories or
hopefully feel pain without being able
to block all those processes at once
many surgeries would be way too
traumatic to perform ancient medical
texts from Egypt Asia and the Middle
East all described early anesthetics
containing things like opium poppy
Mandrake fruit and alcohol today
anesthesiologists often combine regional
inhalational and intravenous agents to
get the right balance for a surgery
regional anesthesia blocks pain signals
from a specific part of the body from
getting to the brain pain and other
messages travel through the nervous
system as electrical impulses regional
anesthetics work by setting up an
electrical barricade they bind to the
proteins in neurons cell membranes that
let charged particles in and out and
lock out positively charged particles
one compound that does this is cocaine
whose pain-killing effects were
discovered by accident when an
ophthalmology intern got some on his
tongue it's still occasionally used as
an anesthetic but many of the more
common regional anesthetics have a
similar chemical structure and work the
same way but for major surgeries where
you need to be unconscious you'll want
something that acts on the entire
nervous system including the brain
that's what inhalational anesthetics do
in Western medicine diethyl ether was
the first common one
it was best known as a recreational drug
until doctors started to realize that
people sometimes didn't notice injuries
they received under the influence in the
1840s they started sedating patients
with ether during dental extractions and
surgeries
nitrous oxide became popular in the
decades that followed and is still used
today
although ether derivatives like
sevoflurane are more common inhalational
anesthesia is usually supplemented with
intravenous anesthesia which was
developed in the 1870s common
intravenous agents include sedatives
like propofol which induce
unconsciousness and opioids like
fentanyl which reduce pain these general
anesthetics also seem to work by
affecting electrical signals in the
nervous system normally the brain's
electrical signals are a chaotic chorus
as different parts of the brain
communicate with each other that
connectivity keeps you awake and aware
but as someone becomes anesthetized
those signals become calmer and more
organized suggesting that different
parts of the brain are talking to each
other anymore there's a lot we still
don't know about exactly how this
happens several common anesthetics bind
to the G ABA a receptor in the brains
neurons they hold the Gateway open
letting negatively charged particles
flow into the cell negative charge
builds up and acts like a log jam
keeping the neuron from transmitting
electrical signals the nervous system
has lots of these gated channels
controlling pathways for movement memory
and consciousness most anesthetics
probably act on more than one and they
don't act on just the nervous system
many anesthetics also affect the heart
lungs and other vital organs just like
early anesthetics which included
familiar poisons like hemlock and
aconite modern drugs can have serious
side effects so an anesthesiologist has
to mix just the right balance of drugs
to create all the features of anesthesia
while carefully monitoring the patient's
vital signs and adjusting the drug
mixture as
anesthesia is complicated but figuring
out how to use it allowed for the
development of new and better surgical
techniques surgeons could learn how to
routinely and safely perform c-sections
reopen blocked arteries replace damaged
livers and kidneys and many other
life-saving operations and each year new
anesthesia techniques are developed that
will ensure more and more patients
survive the trauma of surgery